what what what the phone please tell me
that was you pity it was me I had tacos
for dinner you know my stomach okay good
sorry crowbar no one anyone
they sweep eating I can smell my
you know not actually though I don't
really know I think we got where we came
from but I get the feeling that the door
is closed that stuff will happen
are you are you with me for the fun oh I
have no idea what you're talking about I
think stops breathing all right let's go
so far no that rhymed okay this way pity
okay not that one
we have a crowbar we can go in here it's
really dark and scary that I don't know
what to do about and this I'm this
confused about and here I don't know
even know where I am okay we're here I'm
sorry about that once if I know sorry
where is he okay
place you down over here you can sit
here while I open the door thank you
it's stuck and that's why we used a
crowbar but you cannot use the crowbar I
am sad face now maybe maybe a glass yarn
no you are sorry sorry it's a funnel I
hate you so much
maybe this way I don't even know okay
let's look to make sure that I didn't
forget anything just to be sure I mean I
like sure but - sure is surely sure
Jessie sure what is going on
ah beauty stop doing that
are you really from France yes of course
can't you tell by my accent I don't know
I'm just curious you you Oh pity
we've been here we've been in here
please tell me where to go cuz I don't
really don't know there's like drawers
and [ __ ] but there's never stuff in them
so I'm not even gonna bother this time
here's the door and it's stuck
this got a bit this is definitely it
wasn't it why is it stuck why I'm sorry
buddy it was my fault okay for now but
you are breaking this for me I actually
like that do it again there we go very
satisfying
I think yeah I'm sorry Savannah I'm
leaving you with your cousins have fun
you [ __ ]
he's no help at all guys I'm sorry bye
bye pity don't leave me I know you love
me shut up Stefan I don't love you
I think we're done here we found a
crowbar so that's something and we found
some creepy noises burn I think we're
gonna whoop our self out 360 720 but
this door was stuck right oh [ __ ]
it wasn't holy crown oh yeah we use the
key and then went here and we got the
crowbar and I screamed a little and then
in cream the little just saying I don't
know good combination where to go where
to go where to go confuse I'm confused
I'm confused
where the [ __ ] gamma
I don't know it's so dark I have no
letter you should know that I do
increase the lightning because it's
really hard to see on YouTube
so people like oh it's so light he
doesn't be scared but I can talk English
sure but it is dark for me so I'm your
frame is your door and I've been in here
who close the door
[ __ ] [ __ ] maybe it was some here
right yeah I probably was me
I'm looking for the exit right now
that's so stupid I am
but sense of direction not something I
was born with
yeah same yes I I think it's here yes No
No No
No okay there was maybe it's no it's
it's it's
I know remember
yeah
yes being lost I mean I knew that I knew
I was gonna do that we can even pick it
up afterwards that's amazing this
crowbar looks so far
[Music]
okay
since we don't have safe on oh I am a
red goo that pumps very sexually just
saying it depends who you are
I'm scared Morris are you anyone coming
are you coming for me come at me bro
bring it dining okey okay
he found me as I ride this monster claws
at my door it to another phone my dog
beams down on me quickly oh it's it's
the Stephano really ironic how long it
tried to reach the next three album only
oh it's Alexander no only some sentiment
maybe it's that other guy which I don't
remember the name Oh perhaps I believe
return one day he managed to do so a
little a vengeance burns blah blah blah
how long until the real assassin I saw
this fall how many likes will he'd steal
away before he last it off
I suppose it matters not my time has
come to an end
forgive me it was not it was not fast
enough
Stefano do you ain't no it said Stefano
I'm sure what is this Wow ha ha I only
laid a [ __ ] candle what the boy was
for me uh only little candle why why why
also follow I need you Stefan oh where
are you class at time No please come
back to me I'm sorry ok we have a key to
the dining hall a silver key Daniel I
have no [ __ ] clue where the dining
hall is hello just red goo no problem
I've been in this situation many times
you could say our an expert but maybe it
was the fan Oh
maybe it's systemic it's a funnel I see
no toilet though maybe you took a crap
on that
the final
okay maybe it's over here cuz I don't
know maybe it's the door was stuck and I
have a keen nose it's not stuck anymore
very interesting wait oh it's the other
door ah yes
genius yes I am a genius you all know it
I know it
actually I don't know it you know that
don't know it I think we shouldn't go in
this is kind of saying that oh it
doesn't really make sense to have a
dining hall here though because it's
like books and stuff so I'm I don't know
I don't like books it's not in my dining
hall that's stuck let's use the key it
doesn't work
[ __ ] great it doesn't work yes I hate
you
I thought think that we are maybe down
here because I have stuff and stuff is
always good and
my mind can't think of more things I
think that I need to sit down here for a
minute
yes there's no fire side fix I'm taking
this chair with me now
I mean I like shares it shouldn't be a
problem
oh yeah about this there's a grinding in
their door oh yeah that was Stefan Oh
having sex I forgot sorry Stefan Oh but
closet and door does not work apparently
okay now I have that sorted out it's
gone here maybe something here and we
have nothing
oh yeah oh yeah that's not good they I
have a share though so it's school
I have no idea why I'm sure but I do I
want that's like sorry this is not a
dining hall I know there's one other
door that's stuck and that's I think at
this one but I already checked this one
didn't I yes I did I'm a genius
I'm walking in circles I know what it to
do I should close this store no I should
am i talking a lot today I get the
feeling ham Hey no I place you there
so I remember because otherwise I'll
forget see how smart I am genius I am a
genius with it Stefano's voice I would
guess it was the phone Allah saw that
said it but I guess I'm not a genius
because I'm walking back at horse whip
my hair back and forth I whip my penis
back and forth with my penis back in for
it no not here either I'm seriously
seriously trying to find X now but I
really really can't
I'm trying the hardest I'm a [ __ ]
trihard right now where is the exit okay
here maybe
no yeah no [ __ ] I thought I had the
exit maybe here
dining [ __ ] Hall can you please tell
me where it is
okay it's gotta be left or right a
little locking clock off gonna be come
on a little Bluff okay yes I made a
massive okay so we have a crowbar in
dining hall key why we have a dining
hall okay I guess it's time to figure
out
there's one there oh there's four of
them I have to collect I guess we can
make out he never wants to make out
I hate that I resent that
I don't trust you okay so let's go in
here
cuz I really don't know where else to go
archives yeah
I think that'll be enough for recording
for today cus because hello okay we can
continue actually let's continue this is
dark and scary and I need to find
Stefano I need him I need sofa no let's
go in here like who lit this up well
then who did this set the exciting new
mood I mean news really what bookshelves
and stuff I don't read so it's cool
open this door see what happens hello
are you in here it's a phone oh I Love
You Stefan oh please come back to me so
far though so far though I need your
cell phone oh please please please
please please don't kill me don't kill
me don't kill me
that was nothing I'm a man
I don't
it's dark I have no oil and the cracking
makes my butthole feel weird I can't
explain it either I talked to a doctor
about it he said that I shouldn't put
condoms up there but I'm curious to see
I should stop talking okay oh yeah
uh-huh all right let's go oh no no no no
no no this does not look good
okay this looks really really bad let's
just camp the wall
[Music]
yeah ask me what it feels like seven a
disguise so Vendela telling Kurt Russell
homie this ain't real life I'll be
making good on my promises honesty is
pop it in spite of it is missing but I
realized I could be better than I was
later on my feet
cooking up this song when we fire up